ما الذي ركزت عليه جلسه مجلس الامن فيما
يتعلق بالاوضاع في
غزه مرحبا غنوه هو موضوع التهجير القصري
للفلسطينيين من قطاع غزه
وكان هناك اجماع لافت ودون اي استثناء على
رفض اي محاوله او مساعي او جهود ل تهجير
الفلسطينيين من قطاع غزه قصر بطبيعه الحال
مع تباين المواقف بعد ذلك حول ما اذا كان
ما يجري حاليا من عمليات عدائيه وحرب
اسرائيليه على السكان هو ضمن مخطط للتهجير
القصري ام لا بطبيعه الحال سمعنا مندوب
فلسطين رياض منصور وكذلك مندوب الجزائر
ومندوب روسيا
وال المندوب روسيا هذا على سبيل المثال
يشيرون الى بطرق مختلفه الى ان ما يجري هو
ضمن مخطط ل التهجير القصري فيما تذهب
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الى رفض اي
مساعي للضغط على الفلسطينيين لمغادره
القطاع ومن ان من انه لابد من السماح
للسكان الذين غادروا مناطقهم
بالعوده اليها و رفض اي ضغوط من اجل
اخراجهم من مناطقهم بطبيعه الحال ايضا رفض
امريكي للتصريحات الوارده من اكثر من
مسؤول
اسرائيلي فيما يتعلق
ب التهجير القصري بريطانيا ايضا ذهبت الى
ذات الموقف ولكن سمعنا من اغلب الاعضاء في
المجلس وكذلك ايضا في الاحاطه اللتين
قدمهما وكيل الامين العام للشؤون
الانسانيه وكذلك مساعده الامين العام
لشؤون حقوق الانسان في الواقع في
الاحاطه صوره قاتمه كما هو حال الوضع في
قطاع غزه وهي صوره تشير في الواقع الى انه
لم يترك
للفلسطينيين خيار في الواقع باستثناء
استسلامهم لمساله اللجوء القهري امر او
القصري امر رفضه بطبيعه الحال المسؤولان
مندوب روسيا قال ان هناك استراتيجيه شامله
في هذا الامر وهو ان يكون امام
الفلسطينيين اما الموت او مغادره القطاع
رافضا هذا المسعى غنوه المجلس الان ينعقد
لمناقشه الاوضاع المتوتره جنوب البحر
الاحمر بعد الضربات الامريكيه البريطانيه
المشتركه امس